hey this is presto Walker reminding you
to mind your decisions
here's a warm-up puzzle before the main
puzzle a thief tells the truth on Monday
Wednesday and Friday and he lies on the
other days one day the thief said I will
tell the truth tomorrow
on which day did the thief say this I
think Greg from Hungary for suggesting
this problem now on to the main puzzle a
theif lies on six days of the week but
on one day the same day each week he
only speaks the truth on three
consecutive days he makes the following
statements on day one I lie on Monday
and Tuesday on day two it's now Thursday
Saturday or Sunday on day three I lie on
Wednesday and Friday the question is on
which day does the thief speak the truth
thanks to yura in Holland for suggesting
this problem pause the video if you'd
like to give it a try
when you're ready keep watching to learn
how to solve this problem
[Music]
let's get started with the warm-up
puzzle let's write the days of the week
and note that the thief tells the truth
on Monday Wednesday and Friday and lies
on all of the other days now suppose the
thief says I will tell the truth
tomorrow on a Monday on a Monday he has
to tell the truth but the truth is that
he's going to lie the next day so on a
truthful day the thief would have to say
I will lie tomorrow this is true for all
of the truthful days so it's not
possible that the thief says this on a
Monday Wednesday or Friday we eliminate
these as possibilities what about
Tuesday Thursday or Sunday on those days
the thief lies and has to say a lie that
I will lie tomorrow so again we can
eliminate these possibilities that only
leaves Saturday on Saturday the thief
lies and the thief is actually going to
lie the next day on Sunday so the thief
will in fact lie and say I will tell the
truth tomorrow
the answer is Saturday now let's solve
the main puzzle the thief tells the
truth on a single day of the week
so either the thief is lying on all of
the days 1 2 & 3 or the thief is telling
the truth on exactly one of the days to
figure out which of these possibilities
is true let's consider the statements on
day 1 and day 3 will write the days of
the week and note that each of these
days the thief could be telling the
truth or lying suppose that the thief is
lying on both of these days in order
that the statement on day 1 be false the
thief would have to tell the truth on
one of the days Monday or Tuesday
similarly in order that the statement on
day 3 be false the thief would have to
be telling the truth on Wednesday or
Friday now this is a problem because
there's only one day that the thief is
telling the truth and these implications
don't overlap they're incompatible imp
occassions therefore the thief cannot
lie on both days one and three one of
these statements has to be the truthful
day
so either the thief is telling the truth
on day one and lying on day three or
vice versa furthermore since the thief
has to be telling the truth on day one
or day three that means we know that
thief is lying on the other day day two
this is because there's only one
truthful day in the week which is either
day one or day three so what do we get
knowing that day two has to be a lie the
statement on day two is that it's now
Thursday Saturday or Sunday if this
statement was made on a Thursday
Saturday or Sunday then it would be a
true statement but the thief has to be
lying so the statement has to be made on
a lying day which is Monday Tuesday
Wednesday or Friday so now we need to
figure out which of day one or day three
is the truth day let's suppose that day
one is the truth day and day three is a
lie in order that day three be a lie we
would need the possible truth day which
is day one to be on either Wednesday or
Friday
now if the truth day was on Wednesday
and that's day one then day two would
have to be the following day which is on
a Thursday if it was on Friday
the following day would have to be
Saturday and we have a problem here
day two would have to be on a Thursday
or Saturday which is impossible because
day two has to be on Monday Tuesday
Wednesday or Friday so this possibility
cannot be true it instead must be true
that day one is a lie and day three is
the truth day
so if day one is a lie the truth day
would have to be on Monday or Tuesday
and the truth day is day three if the
truth day day three was on a Monday then
the day before would have to be on a
Sunday the output day two on a Sunday we
can see this is not possible because day
two has to be on Monday Tuesday
Wednesday or Friday so we'll eliminate
this possibility and we'll consider if
day three the truth day is on a Tuesday
in that case day two would have to be
the day before on a Monday and that's
not a problem because that is a possible
day for day two then day one would have
to be on a Sunday and there's no
contradiction there so this is our
answer
day three has to be the truth day and on
Tuesday the truthful day is Tuesday so
it's a pretty complicated logic puzzle
but it is possible to work out if you go
through the details of very carefully
thanks for watching and for making mind
your decisions one of the best channels
on YouTube thanks for watching and
thanks for your support
[Music]